welcome everyone to our second panel of
the day of the morning on the future of
the Republican Party my name is Michael
Anton I am lecturer and research fellow
at the Kirby Center of the cut of the
colleges Hillsdale colleges Kirby Center
here in Washington DC just a few miles
from here where as you heard last night
we are launching a brand new program
this week at graduate school for
statesmanship and politics and to
actually already underway we've got some
students there studying and we expect
this to grow into something really
really big and important and I'm excited
to be a part of it really excited to be
a part of it one of the reasons that I
wanted to come here and was very glad
when I was was hired to come here so I
know all three of the people in this
panels will be very easy for me to
introduce them without notes David as
rad is a fellow at the Heritage
Foundation a dear friend of mine for
what that's worth he may want to disavow
it and he's been spending a lot of his
time lately thinking deeply about
partisan politics and particularly the
intersection of identity politics and
what effect that has on the American
two-party system and on the political
system more broadly Allen gelles I was a
long time historian and professor at
Gettysburg College I was also recently
taken up an affiliation with Princeton
University
so that institution has risen in my
estimation by the nature of that higher
I think can think of a few people
especially as an old student of Lincoln
myself like I think a few people better
equipped to talk about the the future of
the Republican Party simply because I
think there's hardly a person on earth
if there is anyone who knows more about
the origins and the history of the
Republican Party than professor Gelles
oh and therefore he's a very
well-positioned to speak about his
future
he's also if you if you've never heard
him speak every every speech he does is
it is a bit of performance art in the
best sense I don't know how he does it
because there's no tapes of these
nineteenth-century orders but I imagine
when I hear him I remember the first
time I heard him I was quite blown away
by how polished practiced and really
impactful it was that somehow he
unearthed tapes before
courting devices were even invented and
he learned how the speakers of the past
traded in their art and I was quite
amazed and I I think you probably will
be too Henry Olson another dear friend
of mine for many years I think he's he's
here for a lot of reasons but one
overarching reason is there's just
nobody who better understands the
political tides and currents at a very
granular district-by-district percentage
points numbers level and he can take
hard confusing maybe even intimidating
and boring data and make it extremely
accessible and understandable and you
know in terms that an audience that
maybe doesn't want to swim around in
spreadsheets all day looking at numbers
his eyes might glaze over at that I
would include myself in that he can he
can take that and put it into words in a
way that just makes sense of all of that
and just simply the best election
watcher I know right now I would say
also he's a fellow at the ethics and
Public Policy Center and he writes a
daily column in The Washington Post
again another another reason to think
slightly more highly of that institution
which is if you want to know if you want
to know really what's going on in the
and the run-up to the 2020 election in
detail follow that column so I am the
chair and I think I have fulfilled my
duties my only other duty is to make
sure everybody stays on time I means I'm
gonna give them the hook if they go over
we are going in the order you see that
means mr. Ezra is your first speaker
thank you Mike and thank you to
Hillsdale for inviting me it's quite an
honor to be participating in this
Constitution Day celebration I was not
so lucky as to go to Hillsdale they
don't have a campus in Canada last time
I checked but I did go to grad school at
the University of Dallas where I had the
pleasure of studying under Tom West and
RJ prestigio distrito and with Kevin
slack I then worked under Matt Spalding
at the Heritage Foundation for three
years and over the years at Heritage
I've had the pleasure of teaching many
Hillsdale interns and I'm always
impressed by the how well their minds
and character are well formed most
universities
it seems to me run the business of
delivering credentials Hillsdale is in
the business of ensuring that they get
an education
regrettably I was not asked to talk
about the life of the mind but to deal
in much less dignified subject albeit
one that is quite important namely the
future of the Republican Party as I see
it there is a fundamental asymmetry
between our two political parties in
America I'll state the matter bluntly so
as to highlight the difference the
Republican Party wants to win elections
in order to enact Republican policies
whereas the Democratic Party wants to
win elections to ensure that the rep the
Republican party never wins another
election the Democrats and the left more
generally have flipped von Klaus Lewis's
maxim on its head politics for them is
the continuation of war by other means
the goal is to defeat the enemy now in
the immediate sense the enemy is defined
as the Republican Party especially the
racist orange man who was installed by
the Russians in the White House but
Trump and the GOP find their support
amongst all of the deplorable who cling
to their guns and their religion
conservative media and all of the
institutions of the vast right-wing
conspiracy that occupies the progressive
imagination they too must be brought to
heel these enemies need not be
annihilated but they must be subdued the
GOP and the right may continue to exist
but only as a controlled neutered
opposition that does not challenge in
any meaningful way the progressive
project to fundamentally transform the
United States of America into a
romanticized version of Sweden I say
romanticized because Sweden has
universal school choice in private
health care no elective late term
abortions or minimum wage and it does
not bestow birthright citizenship upon
the children of illegal aliens this
however never figures in Bernie Sanders
is glowing accounts of the nation as a
result of this asymmetry there is a
clarity of purpose or resolve and dare I
say a ruthlessness in the Democratic
Party that one rarely finds in the
Republican Party they are at war with us
they have openly said so but too many of
us prefer not to admit this they play to
win while we just play maybe not to lose
too badly I was at a dinner with some
several with several prominent
conservative intellectuals in Washington
DC last month and the consensus around
the table was we should use whatever
political power we now have to enact
policies like school choice that will
shield this from what will come wants
Elizabeth Warren or Kamala Harris become
president now listen this is not a
foolish way to think this I readily
concede but here's the question that I
put to the table and that I would put to
you this morning do you think anyone on
the Left ever thinks like this do you
think they ever ask themselves well what
can we do to make sure that they're not
mean to us when they win an election of
course they don't because Democrats
don't think like losers because
Democrats are not afraid of Republicans
and can you blame them at most the GOP
will Ford for a few years their great
ambitions like Medicare for all amnesty
for all or the green New Deal but it's
not like they have to fear that the
Republican Party is ever going to repeal
any one of their major programs if it's
once it's implemented need I remind you
that the GOP prom
for eight years to repeal and replace
Obamacare and when they finally had the
opportunity to do so they flinched the
first order of business therefore for
the GOP if it wants to have a future is
an attitude adjustment we need a more
spirited Republican party a republican
party that fights with the same
intensity and clarity of purpose as the
Democratic Party does a Republican Party
that fights to win and this is one area
where the current figurehead of the
party has much to teach his fellow
Republicans now in praising him I am NOT
blind to his shortcomings presidents
Trump's flaws are readily apparent and
let me remind you they have received
more attention than those of any other
president in American history he does
however also possess certain virtues
that are worthy of emulation chief of
which is his spiritedness the president
may not always pick his battles well nor
does he always fight them in the most
prudent way or with decorum for that
matter but no one can question his will
to fight this I suspect accounts for
much of his popularity amongst the
Republican base and CERN independence
and it accounts for much of the horror
he inspires and Democrats a Republican
who fights unapologetically what a sight
this is not what we have come to expect
from the party that gave us Mitt Romney
Paul Ryan and Jeb Bush now I realize
that some of you may find my counsel
distasteful wouldn't it be better you
may ask if you know Trump in the GOP
didn't escalate things wouldn't it be
nicer if we had a more mild-mannered
person at the head of the party I don't
know maybe a gentleman we are living in
turbulent times the country is in the
midst of a cold civil war and we are not
dealing with an opponent who abides by
the gentleman's code of conduct the
times call for more aggressive men and
women gentlemen are admirable in many
regards but they have their limitations
a gentleman for example
not be comfortable humiliating a woman
in public this you will admit poses a
problem if the woman in question is
Kamala Harris Elizabeth Warren or who
knows Michelle Obama now ultimately it's
not enough to want to fight you gotta
fight for the right things and it's not
enough to fight for the right things you
got to fight through to victory so what
should the Republican Party fight for
the immediate priority it seems to me is
to prevent the Democratic Party and
their allies on the left from enacting
policies that will all but guarantee
Democratic political hegemony they
currently have their sights set on three
areas to ensure that and these are
further restricting political speech
transforming the electoral system and
changing the demographics of the country
through continued large-scale
immigration allow me to explain them
first on free speech America is
currently the only Western nation in the
world that has not criminalized
so-called
hate speech now I say so-called because
at issue is not racial slurs or
Holocaust denial but if we criminalize
hate speech we would essentially curtail
into a large extent forbid deliberation
on major political issues confronting
the country in the left's expansive
conception of hate speech calling for
less immigration advocating for welfare
reform opposing the transgender agenda
or simply defending the Christian
conception of marriage could all be
considered forms of hate speech let me
put it to you bluntly hate speech
according to the left encompasses an
awful lot of Republican conservative and
Christian speech the Supreme Court it is
true has so far stood strong on the
issue but conservatives must remain
vigilant the court after all is not
bound by its own precedents and it will
often bow to public opinion and change
its mind on a whim
now the left's assault on free speech
goes well beyond restricting what we are
allowed to say the Democratic Party all
will also wants to further restrict
ability to fund political speech by
enacting ever tighter campaign finance
restrictions the rhetoric they deploy is
quite seductive we want to have everyone
have an equal voice we want to end undue
influence but the effectual truth of
such policies as Machiavelli might say
would be to give the media and even more
outsized voice in influencing elections
because the press remember is never
subject to campaign finance laws and
while they like to speak of earned media
for the various candidates don't be
fooled all media is bestowed by the
media the First Amendment as understood
by the framers protects not just your
right to speak but your right to publish
and promote your views and a republican
party that wants to win should therefore
set its sights on dismantling most of
the campaign finance architecture that
has been built up in America in the past
four decades we cannot win if we play by
the rules they rigged in their own favor
lastly the Republicans really need to
take seriously look into the very
credible accusations that the major tech
platforms Twitter Facebook and in
particular Google are influencing our
politics by manipulating what
information Americans can see online
right now senators Cruz and Holly are
basically the only two vocal voices in
the party who take this threat seriously
big tech has a political agenda these
are not just regular for-profit
corporations
and that agenda is not just progressive
it is anti conservative but their
activities and their algorithms are
shrouded in secrecy the Republican Party
has to wake up to the fact that threats
to Liberty can come from the private
sector and not just the state second
looking at the electoral system the
Democratic Party wants to transform our
electoral system to skew it in its favor
and they want to do this primarily by
one of two ways the first is to make it
easier for anyone to vote by essentially
eliminate
any safeguards on voter fraud now
concerns for voter fraud they say you
know what they are they're racist dog
whistles to disenfranchise minorities
now I gotta tell you I'm not a citizen
yet I'm working on it but as a foreigner
living in America that is the one thing
I absolutely cannot wrap my mind amount
might wrap my mind around wrap my mound
or wrap my mind around about this great
country I so admire how in God's green
earth can you allow people to vote
without showing ID how can you not
demand proof of citizenship when it
comes time to register and while I'm at
it how do you not check whether people
are registered in more than one state
it's surreal
even we silly Canadians don't do this
the Democratic Party basically wants an
honor system when it comes to voting the
result of village would be maximum fraud
it therefore has to be a top priority
for the GOP especially at the state
level to protect the integrity of the
ballot but the Democrats don't just want
everyone to vote including by the way
incarcerated felons you can thank Bernie
Sanders and the ACLU for that genius
idea they also want to get rid of that
pesky electoral college that keeps on
allowing the GOP to steal elections the
way they did in 2000 and 2016 therefore
they are actively pushing the national
popular vote initiative it's now been
adopted by 15 states in the District of
Columbia and the left is pouring
millions of dollars into this initiative
that must be counter meanwhile the
Republican Party has devoted more
resources to defending the carried
interest loophole than to defending the
electoral college then there is this
question of demographic change
so we conservatives love to quote Andrew
bright bright you know the dictum right
culture is upstream from politics and
this is our way of excusing ourselves
for having lost so much ground in
America over the past century but it
seems to me that this is not how the
left and the Democratic Party look at
things they seem to think that
demographics
is upstream from both culture and
politics and that if they can change the
demographics of the country primarily
through large-scale immigration they can
secure a permanent majority now it's no
secret that immigrants and their
children overwhelmingly vote for
Democrats so when the Democrats say
diversity is our strength
you better believe them it's just that
the hour in the sentence is not America
but the Democratic Party and so they
want to abolish the border they want to
attract even more immigrants with the
promise of free health care and a
reassurance that in America we don't
enforce our laws all of this paving the
way for a glorious amnesty that would
turn Texas Florida and Arizona into
California now I'm not saying that
Republicans should oppose all
immigration because of this I just think
that when the enemy is giving you his
war plans you'd be foolish not to take
them seriously I don't know what the
future demographics of the country are
but I'm not a Republican strategist what
worries me is that the Republican
strategists don't seem to think about
this either at the very least it seems
to me that Republicans should hold the
line strong and oppose any and all
amnesty the last time we did anestine 86
there were 5 million illegals in this
country today there are anywhere between
11 and 29 million now I'll end by saying
this these three priorities are the bare
minimum if the GOP just wants to hold
the line if it wants to have a future
but these are not going to constitute a
victory the GOP also needs to go on the
offensive and that really means thinking
like the left and going after the
centers of power of the enemy and in
this case it's the universities
Hillsdale and a handful of other
colleges accepted our universities are
deeply deeply corrupt they do not serve
the common good they do not promote the
discovery truth they are not forming
citizens for Republican self-government
they have largely become madrasahs of
higher indoctrination
also function as the Rd Department for
the left America needs a
transformational higher education reform
agenda aimed at dealing a devastating
blow to the universities and the
colleges first the GOP should do to them
were trumped it to the media exposed the
charlatans and humiliate them no more
honoring of these corrupt institutions
second you go after the money America
cannot continue to subsidize these
universities to the tune of billions of
dollars a year that means in other words
give your money to hell still not not to
these universities - yeah by the way
that's the thing for conservatives I'm
always bewildered to see red-blooded
patriotic god-fearing conservatives
giving money to their alma mater
unless that alma mater is one of a
handful of schools in this country that
take education seriously this is not the
school you went to 50 years ago we need
to restrict the forty billion dollars a
year we sent to them in research funds
and we need to completely revamp the
government-backed student loan industry
I'll end by saying this I'll like to
raise the one question I have so far not
addressed and that regrettably I won't
have the time to address because I'm
afraid of Anton who wants me to stick to
my time and that is what's the positive
thing that the Republican Party should
fight for and I think that the shortest
and broadest possible answer has to be
America the Republican Party should be
the party of Americans who love America
and Americans period the party of
unabashed
patriotic pride in the accomplishments
of this great country the party of
Americans who cling not just to their
guns in their religion but to their
capitalism their Constitution their land
their borders their past their language
their spirit the party of all those who
see themselves as Americans first
thank you
[Applause]
and after the earthquake a still small
voice when I was asked to speak to this
panels topic the future of the
Republican Party the question which came
at once to my mind was why are you
asking a historian because my principal
preoccupation is with understanding the
past but in the spirit of an earlier
Republican who suggested that if we
could first know where we are and
whither we are tending we could better
judge what to do and how to do it let me
take the historical turn anyway and ask
what the Republican Party has been from
its origins in the mid 1850s before
speculating on what it will or should be
what has made the Republican Party we
tend to identify the two dominant
political parties by the policies they
espouse either through their
presidential candidates or their
national platforms and almost all that
we have heard thus far this morning has
been about policies which are all about
the present and the immediate but that
assumes that all that makes a party or
its policy formulations if that were the
case American history should be
populated by an exuberance of third
party movements and it isn't this is
because beneath the easily visible shape
of policies there exists for both
parties an iceberg like submergence of
what may be called political culture
political culture provides each party
with its long-term ballast
of values and principles policies form
the tip of the iceberg the visible part
political culture is what lies below the
visible but gives it its coherence and
consistency this incidentally is why
third parties tend to be so few and so
short-lived because third parties are
usually the creatures of personalities
or purely of policies and have no
ballast of their own political culture
is the long delay of politics for every
significant policy issue Republicans and
Democrats have significantly different
answers but the difference lies in the
different political cultures from which
they have emerged so let us talk first
about the political cultures of the
parties and only then ask what the
future of the Republican Party will be
in its beginning will be found its
future the political culture of the
American parties has been shaped around
seven shall we say arguments those seven
arguments are the economic system the
political center morals style occupation
family and philosophy for an economic
system the democratic ideal has always
been stasis while the Republican word
has been mobility for the political
center the guiding Democratic notion has
been the tribal or the local and that
presents to us today the form
incidentally of identity politics while
the Republican alternative has been the
nation as a whole so that an American
identity is understood as superior to a
racial or gender identity for Democrats
morals are matters of invention
while for Republicans morals have been
natural for Democrats style has been
about passion while for Republicans
style has been about reason the
preferred Democratic occupation has been
subsistence and for Republicans it has
been entrepreneurial the Democratic
concept of family has been companionate
while for Republicans family has been
organic and in terms of philosophy
Democrats are the disciples even today
of Hegel and the tribe of Hegel they are
romantics while Republicans are the
disciples even today of the moderate
enlightenment which is to say of Locke
Madison and Lincoln understanding this
yields us the long term insight that we
need to ask the question of the hour
about the Republican Party's future for
in fact the Republican the political
culture of the Republican Party remains
one of only two options in American
political life and will persist despite
the ephemera of policies but it will
have to manage those policies
intelligently and consistently with its
underlying political culture if that
future is to be a successful one what
will it take then for the Republican
Party to build a successful future out
of its political culture for most of
republicanism life as either the
Republican Party or is its forerunner
the Whig party Democrats were
ineffective control of American policies
that was true during the long run of the
Jeffersonian Jacksonian Democrats from
1800 to 1860 and during the even longer
run of progressive Democrats from 1932
to 2016 with the brief interregnum of
Ronald Reagan
under that shadow we can recognize
fairly easily
the Democratic political culture that
has dictated Democratic policy begin
with the first of my seven arguments the
economic system those of us here have
lived much of our lives under the
economic direction of Democrats and they
like their Jacksonian forebears have
preferred an economy of stasis in which
an administrative and corporate elite
recruits a proletarian class as its ally
in corralling and suppressing the middle
class who are the Paragons of mobility
and are seen as dangerous precisely for
aspiring to mobility the evidence of
this is all around us between 1940 and
2016 economic mobility rates in the
United States have declined from 92
percent to just 50 percent we are now as
immobile a society as the United Kingdom
and while Democrats complain about
economic inequality they are the party
who benefits the most from it and
promotes the policies most likely to
ensure it let us take New York City as
one example although New York City has
long been as unanimously Democratic as
any American Center can be one-fifth of
Gotham's residents live below the
poverty line the number of homeless
people in New York City has increased by
thirty seven point four percent between
2007 and 2016 overall no meaningful
reduction in poverty in New York City
has occurred in the last 20 years that
this seems to cause modern Democrats
nothing beyond rhetorical heartburn is
plain they are concerned about eating
equality is at base a plea for the
reinstatement of stasis
since they are forebears sneered at
economic mobility as a threat to their
economic privilege Republicans of an
earlier time knew what this stasis was
called and to it they opposed the
principles of free labor and self making
so must Republicans of the present day
and the future the promotion of that
mobility also governed Republican policy
on trade Republicans inherited from
their Whig forerunners a commitment to
the protection of American commerce
whether agricultural or manufacturing
although tariffs have often been a bad
word in American political life that is
because tariffs were a bad word first
for Jacksonian Democrats and then for
wilsonian progressives partly this was
because free-trade progressives had
already adopted the notion of a global
economy in which the fate of the
American producer was held to be
subordinate to the overall global system
and partly because tariffs offered
benefits only to the upwardly mobile not
to an elite who had already arrived
the founders in the first Congress under
the Constitution had no hesitation about
imposing average tariffs of eighty one
and a half percent he was under
Democratic leadership that tariffs were
lowered to just twenty percent while the
first Republican tariffs under Abraham
Lincoln once more rose to 49 percent and
stayed that way until the Wilson
administration the purpose of the tariff
for Republicans was simple encourage the
development of the domestic economy by
shielding it from the economic warfare
practiced by the European powers but
tariffs are only one example and not
even those pressing example of a larger
understanding Republicans must have
about the relationship of Gov
and the economy from the days of Thomas
Jefferson the Democratic ethos has
always seen government as the restrainer
critic and opponent of Commerce and that
fundamental attitude has not changed it
did not change on the first panel this
morning
Republicans have understood the role of
government as that of enabler from the
days of Henry Clay and his American
system of internal improvements to
Lincoln's sponsorship of the Homestead
Act the largest single privatization of
government assets in American history
and the Pacific Railway Act latter day
Republicans will be in good company if
they understand that Commerce is as much
a matter of national security as drones
and missiles the Republican future will
also rest on a reawakening to the
importance of morals and family to its
identity the prevailing nihilism which
reduces all politics to considerations
of power and places government
regulatory authority at the center of
society rather than families and
mediating institutions bodes well
neither for the Republican Party nor for
the Republic itself the Republicans of
the 1860s made their rallying cry
against slavery and appeal to natural
rights and the centrality of the family
and marriage bond we have taught
legalized slavery long behind us but the
arguments that the slaveholding
oligarchs used to defend slavery have
eerie valence 'as to those today used to
promote abortion on demand indifference
to the flourishing of families and the
centralization of social authority in an
immoral elite Republicans of today and
tomorrow
must find their way back to a national
ethic of not
morality and with it a healthy division
of power between the state and civil
society which is to say rediscovering
their political culture it has been said
that Republicans cannot hope to make a
case for these principles in the face of
a revolutionary new American demographic
yet Republicans we're facing an even
more revolutionary demographic in the
1860s when totally unrestrained
immigration enabled new demographic
groups Irish Italians Germans to
approach the thresholds of political
power
yet Republicans triumphed because while
immigrant groups begin with very
distinct identities the promotion of
intermarriage and economic mobility
gradually erased those distinctives
today we are witness to a substantial
growth in Asian and Latino voters whom
it is feared Republicans have lost to
the blandishments of their Democratic
opponents but Latino voters over two
generations gradually lose their sense
of Hispanic particularity by the third
and fourth generation of Latino
immigrants as high as fifty percent no
longer identify themselves as Latino but
simply as American thus the Hispanic and
Asian electorates precisely because they
are in a state of generational flux by
no means spell the end of a Republican
future any more than did their European
predecessors a century or more before
already among African Americans a
generational shift is apparent as
younger African Americans in 2016
pulled noticeably shy of democratic
progressives and continued to do so in
their chilliness toward Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren
but the predictability of this in turn
depends for Republicans on a
reappropriation and promotion of its own
political culture
I could perhaps go on further into
re-examining the philosophy the style
the occupation of Republican political
culture bought as jebediah nightlinger
immortally admitted while I have the
inclination the maturity and the
wherewithal unfortunately I don't have
the time it is worth saying however that
the most curiously encouraging note for
the Republican future has been the
vanishing of democratic complacency it
was a trademark of the Democratic Party
ever since the New Deal that the future
was understood to be inexorably bending
in its direction and that the task of
its intellectuals was to silence
complaints about a lead ism and the
effacement of democracy by identity
politics the election of 2016 and the
corresponding lurch of the Democratic
Party
beyond progressivism toward
european-style social democracy should
be seen for what it is an ominous
admission of Terror at the revolt of the
deplorable z-- the Republican Party is
the only political entity which can
speak to this revolt if it does not the
Restless will turn instead to
authoritarianism and what we will get is
what Yvonne iliyan the inspiration of
Vladimir Putin calls sovereign democracy
in which the state is unified and
centralized its Authority ceded to an
individual and that individual
glamorized and glorified by
centralization personification and
idealization to resist that temptation
Republicans must find their future in
their past
the battle that began against romantic
oligarchy in 1861 is not over the truth
is we're only in the third round
[Applause]
thank you very much
I want to let you know that the
Washington Post explicitly hired me to
provide some balance for their page
which means at any given day I'm
outnumbered only nine to one which is
right where I want them being at a
Hillsdale Institute Hillsdale of em
reminds me that hills dales intellectual
legacy is descended in modern times -
its President Larry arn from that of his
alma mater Claremont and it would be ill
becoming of me to attend anything
inspired by Claire mount without quoting
either Aristotle or Lincoln in this case
there are three appropriate quotes that
I'd like to start with because they
frame very nicely what I think the
political challenge of the Republican
Party is first from the Nicomachean
ethics where Aristotle talks about all
activity having an end and he says that
in strategy the end is victory so that
for any political party that engages in
strategy no less than any army the aim
must be to win in politics in democratic
politics that means to win elections so
then the question is how does one win
elections in in the modern democracy
well Abraham Lincoln provides the quote
for that in 1850 sent eight he said that
public sentiment is everything with it
nothing is forbidden and without it
nothing can be obtained and he went
ahead and the prove that to himself in a
private letter which was now part of the
collection of Lincoln writings in which
he wrote to himself not words but
numbers
recall that in 1858 senators were
elected not directly by the vote of the
people but through the legislature so
what he needed to do was to win a
majority of state legislators who were
to be elected and this letter contains
two columns one district by district the
votes for the presidential race which
was three ways between a Republican a
Democrat and Millard Fillmore that know
nothing or American Party
and the other the race for governor
which was a two way or another race
which was a two way race between
Democrats and Republicans and through
this what he determined was that the way
to victory was to persuade know-nothings
who obviously were not persuaded by pure
Republican rhetoric to join with the
Republican cause for if he could do that
he could theoretically win a majority so
the question for us then is to assess
strength the question is what is public
sentiment today do we constitute a
majority and if not how do we obtain one
anything else from a political matter
simply pales into insignificance so the
first thing to recognize is movement
conservatives to use the broad term are
not a majority in fact they're not even
a majority of the Republican Party I
wrote a book on this called the four
phases of the Republican Party which
looked at twenty years of exit poll data
prior to Trump and you can conclusively
see that that union that Ted Cruz so
dearly wished for between libertarians
and Tea Partiers and religious right
establishment was at most 1/3 of the
Republican Party's National electorate
in fact Cruz successfully obtained his
goal and had exactly the end I predicted
for him in a series of National Review
essays going back to 2014 defeat he
would have lost to any sentient
Republican because the majority of the
Republican Party exists between the
moderates who remain promoters in the
presidential primaries even as they are
not strong enough in many of their homes
like the San Francisco Bay Area New York
City and Boston to send representatives
to Congress and the group that tells
voters pollsters they are somewhat
conservative which in a short Ward says
the people who prefer John Boehner and
Mitch McConnell to Ted Cruz or Mike Lee
we also know that they're not a majority
even when they contain control of a
Republican electorate over broader
Republican constituencies take the
examples of Sam Brownback and the
current battles going on in Alaska Sam
Brownback was governor of
rasca about as deep red estate as you
can get he pushed through a supply-side
tax cut praised by the americans for tax
reform and virtually every
right-thinking intellectual on economic
policy in the republican party and four
years later he was defeated within
republican primaries by Republican
moderates and somewhat conservatives who
did not like the cuts that this loss of
revenue required to public services and
they joined with Democrats to override
the governor's veto repealing the
entirety of his tax cuts we're going
through the same battle in Alaska right
now where the governor Mike Dunleavy has
said to Alaska voters you've been
defending beyond your means for years
you must cut back and by doing that I
will restore your annual check from the
dividend fund of Alaska and give you
each a thousand four hundred dollars
more now think about that what he's
saying is that if you restrain spending
every family of four will get fifty six
hundred dollars a year that is larger
than any tax cut that any Republican has
proposed in the last 60 years and yet he
sits underwater in personal opinion
ratings he says under 40% and there's a
massive recall that is forming right now
to remove him from office even in red
Alaska people will not choose the
republican movement conservative
economic philosophy so where is public
sentiment if it is not on the right well
we can look at public sentiment by
looking at its voter groups that swing
between the parties because it is clear
that is not democratic either the
Republican Party is behind the
Democratic Party and identification but
the Democratic Party unlike the days of
the 50s and 60s and the 70s when they
can command over half of America as a
default party loyalist sits barely in
the 30s when asked a hard question and
only into the 40s when a stood in a soft
way the Democratic Party thinks it
represents the majority but in fact like
the Republican Party of old only
represents the largest mobilized
minority we can divide the republic the
swing voters into three groups
if we think of it as a menagerie the
Republicans are the elephant's we should
say combining all species of movement
conservative with their more moderate
Boehner right and McConnell I brethren
these are the elephants there are three
swing groups in American politics the
two that are most prominent today I call
rhinos and tigers rhinos are Republicans
in name only
they are suburban educated upper income
Republicans these are the people who
tended to defect to Hillary Clinton but
remained resolutely unsocialized in
their economics and even if they incline
towards some degree of social liberalism
are not fully in the board of the
transformation list progressives who
wish to undo centuries of morality the
Tigers are the group that tunnel Trump
attracts I call them Tigers because it
stands for Trump is great Republicans
these you've got to be creative in my
business these are the people who are
are these are the people who tend to be
blue-collar
they tend to be native-born although
there are more minorities here then you
would believe if you listened to the
media they tend to be groups that move
towards Donald Trump precisely because
he was the only Republican in decades to
respond to what Bill Galston and others
spoke about on the first panel which is
the realities of economic life today
they like protection they like
protection from foreign labor whether
it's through immigration restriction or
trade restriction they like protection
from economic vicissitude which is why
Donald Trump's pledge that unlike Paul
Ryan he was not going to touch Social
Security and Medicare was absolutely
crucial to winning these voters over and
they came in droves they were over seven
million people who voted for President
Obama who voted for Donald Trump and mil
a million to 3 million more who came
from the rules of the not voting into
the Republican rules to elect Donald
Trump they were also the reason he swept
the primary that Republican turnout in
the 2016 primaries and caucuses nearly
equal Democratic for the first time
in history it was not until the last
weekend of voting when California voted
that the Democratic turnout finally
exceeded the Republican turnout people
voted in the Republican primary for
Trump who had never voted for any
Republican in any presidential primary
before how do you bring the Rhinos and
the Tigers together
well the Rhinos are the sort of people
who are supportive of capitalist
economics but capitalism with what you
might call a human faith they are
supportive of economic cuts you know
they favor of economy and government but
not the unwhole sale unraveling of it
they are in favor of the traditional
family but they are not in favor of the
return to the 1950s they are not in
favor of return to a de facto Christian
America where views on sex and gender
roles are dictated by traditional views
taking from the traditional view of the
Bible they are moderates in that sense
neither holy with progressives nor holy
with conservatives on the culture war
Tigers on the other hand are what are
called morally moderate they will revolt
on culture wars only when they see
themselves directly skewered by one side
or the other these are people who like
Donald Trump but did not like Mike
Huckabee in 2008 these are people who do
not like being called deplorable and do
not like having their way of life
attacked daily in the media or by
Democratic leaders this is why sane
Democrats are hoping that Joe Biden can
be the nominee because he's not
threatening to these people on a
cultural dynamic but these are people
who want protection
these are the sort of people who wanted
worker Safety's laws and workmen
compensation back in the 1900s in the
1910s these are the people who were the
party of the New Deal
and interpreted the New Deal nodded in a
socialist manner but in a humane
reforming of capitalism an ER these are
the people who benefited from FHA loans
these are the people who benefited from
expansions of public universities these
are the people for whom
Medicare and Social Security are the
massive anchors on which they rest their
future non-working lives they do not
expect to depend on family a family
which will be unlikely to support them
if these things were gone they do not
depend on local institutions they depend
on Social Security and Medicare for a
comfortable dignified retirement a
republican party that can speak to these
is a republican party that can gain them
right now we have two republican parties
both of which are essentially warring
over minorities coalitions the Trump
coalition which is the elephants plus
the Tigers is a coalition that is
electoral II efficient because Tigers
tend to live in the Upper Midwest and
they can swing the electoral college and
because of the way our Senate is elected
you can have pretty much a lock on the
Senate as long as you have an elephant
and Tiger majority you cannot win the
house with this majority because it has
nothing to the Rhinos that swung the
house over to the Democrats last time
the traditional Republican Party
effectively wants a rhino + elephant
coalition this is the Romney coalition
this was the Paul Ryan coalition this
was a coalition that can deliver the
house and deliver it rather well even
without gerrymander it may not be a
large majority but it is a decent chance
to have a long-term majority it is one
for which the Senate is a coin flip
because it is more suburban and it is
less whirl and it is one that has no
hope of winning the presidency they
claim otherwise but I only have two
minutes and 30 seconds and I don't want
to spend it demolishing their argument
the short-term Republican majority is to
combine the three together
rhinos tigers and elephants oh my this
is something that a modified a modified
trumpism one shorn of its of the
president's distinctive negative aspects
of his personality but one that is more
open to what I call a limited and
energetic government one that is willing
to act not simply stand back in the face
of the realities of the modern
anomic state and one that values
security as an equal measure to liberty
and opportunity that is where the
majority is and that is something that a
left-wing influence if not dominated
Democratic Party would have very
difficult time competing against the
last group is one that I've never
mentioned before Michael gets a new
animal today and that is the RAM what is
a ram the recently arrived minority say
I had to have a nice elephant name for
an animal name for immigrants who are
the Rams the Rams are unlike other
immigrant groups they are distinctly
Asian and in our history they're
distinctly Asian and from Latin and
South America a non-trivial number from
Africa what they are is perhaps the
least Christian of any of our immigrant
groups Hispanics are dramatically lapsed
Catholics and virtually no Asian
immigrant comes from a Christian
background they are also from more
collectivist backgrounds and this they
do share in common with the second wave
of immigration the people from Italians
you know in Eastern Europe who shaped
the 1880 to 1820 migration wave they
will over time become assimilated to
American ways of life and consequently
be more open to American arguments but
the fact remains that even today the
grandchildren and the
great-grandchildren of the immigrants of
that wave are much more open to economic
intervention than the wave of people who
are descended from native British
Protestants stock a Republican Party
that wants to engage with demographic
change has to engage with the Rams on
their own turf and that sense their
merely a different manifestation of the
challenge of engaging with rhinos and
tigers and it is perhaps a act of
hutzpah to invoke the name of Lincoln
with a log walls of sitting to the right
of me but I think that the republicanism
of Lincoln and Reagan one of a limited
but energetic God
one that sees action and inaction as two
sides of the same coin with the thumb
firmly on the scales of Liberty but not
so firmly on the scales of Liberty to
leave one blind to reality that one can
engage with this and if one does this
then I think there's a more than passing
chance that the Republican Party can do
something it has not been able to do
since 1928 and that is to generally
genuinely say that they command the
plurality if not the majority support of
the voters the United States of America
[Applause]
all right Abbi okay here we go I so
being the chair I get to ask the first
question it's one of the privileges of
being a chair now I'm gonna try to split
the difference in a way from that's
three of the presentations I have heard
take a little bit from each and then see
how they respond to this so starting
with Dave when I look at the recent
numbers electoral numbers I think as red
is of course correct that recent
immigrants and their immediate
descendants from the ninth the post 1965
wave attended to vote rough in rough
terms two-to-one Democratic and so if
the demographic change continues the way
it's changing that doesn't spell great
electoral things for the Republican
Party and you know to quote Marco Rubio
from one of the 2016 debates they know
exactly what they're doing
that is the Democrats who are who are
pushing this opposing the wall opposing
any kind of reform and in fact getting
more radical as we watch the Democratic
debates in this season getting more
radical in their insistence that the
country just simply has to be wide open
to anyone forever on the other hand
professor Geller was certainly correct
that the United States has undergone
significant demographic change very
rapidly in high numbers in the past and
has successfully assimilated these
populations and turns many of them
Republican in fact you know built
Republican majorities in part on the
strength of voting patterns of recent
immigrants or at least their descendants
one or two generations down so during
the 2016 campaign one of the things that
I'll be you know just blunt and confess
I was a fairly early Trump supporter I
wasn't one of those who at the end had
to hold my nose and vote for him I did
it sort of enthusiastically and one of
the reasons for that was I thought well
he's breaking the old Republican mode
where the working-class sees the
working-class the lower middle class the
blue-collar the non-college educated
sees the Republican Party is simply just
out to get them not for their interests
you know the party of finance the party
of outsourcing the party of cutting
benefits as Henry mentioned and there
and that party had a very limited appeal
to say the least to this demographic so
it seemed like Trump was the first to
come along who was really going to break
that mold
maybe for a long the prospect of a
long-term realignment of that economic
segment of the electorate aligning with
the Republican Party but given the
reality of demographic change as it's
ongoing in this country the Republican
Party can't success it could maybe
successfully do that but it won't
successfully win elections or build a
majority unless it can get a pretty
significant chunk it doesn't have to be
50% but a pretty significant chunk of
black Hispanic blue collar workers
voters and so on and so if the goal is
to get to at least a plurality that's
bigger than the other guys plurality or
even better yet and enduring majority in
in the low to mid 50s Republican Party
has to do that or I just don't see how
it survives as a party that can win
national elections so my question then
for all three panelists is what are the
prospects for success and if you're you
know the chair of the RNC what do you do
what what are the things that you would
put in place have the party do in order
to make that success more likely I'll
just go in order I think I don't have a
proper answer to that serious and
important question Mike I am and I'm not
speaking for the Heritage Foundation
here I'm speaking as a Canadian
immigrant to the US what gives me pause
about immigration is not the immigrants
it's the elites I mean this is just not
our country anymore immigrants will
assimilate you have no choice but to
assimilate the issue is assimilate into
what into Howard Zinn America's going
into our schools our university our
general culture teaching them that this
is the country that invented slavery and
Jim Crow that is irredeemably racist and
sexist and homophobic encouraging them
to think of themselves as hyphenated
Americans because that's where the
goodies are from the government the
racial preferences the handouts that you
name it you know I there's an anecdote I
like to share that Indians from India
petitioned the Reagan administration to
be reclassified as Asians they were
classified as whites they demanded to be
Asians why because there are government
benefits if you are a minority you get
special loans for minority-owned
businesses so I am
very much in favor of slowing down
immigration because I do not trust in us
in our capacity in our willpower to
assimilate immigrants into Americanists
and independently of any electoral
considerations that gives me a lot of
pause until we regain confidence until
weary conquer the institutions we lost
to the left we're asking to simply swell
the ranks of people who are not going to
think in the right American way because
of us I think they may come here with
the best of intentions we're gonna
encourage them to go the other way
couple of thoughts come to mind here
invoking Lincoln on public sentiment is
an interesting way of understanding
Lincoln as a political figure
public sentiment he said he is
everything with it you can do a great
many things without it nothing but he
did not regard himself as being passive
in the face of public sentiment when he
talked about public sentiment that way
his idea was you shape public sentiment
and you shape it around a certain set of
values one does not see him in the
debates against Stephen Douglas
attempting to temporize to modify to
tone down if anything over the course of
the seven debates of 1858 Lincoln
becomes more trenchant he becomes
sharper so that by the last last two of
the great debates of 1858 Lincoln is now
speaking in broad great terms about the
principles that are at stake in slavery
versus freedom and he does not hesitate
to compare slavery to the rule of Kings
he says it really doesn't matter whether
you're talking about a king who seeks to
bestride the people of his own nation
and live by the fruit of their labor or
one race of men as an apology for
enslaving another race it is the same
tyrannical principle he believed in
shaping public opinion and he believed
the long term shaping was going to make
the difference